the continuing story out of ukraine
ukraine under siege from russian
invaders in multiple cities now and
local officials say the russians are
shelling indiscriminately hitting
hospitals hitting residential areas
russian soldiers are also trying to take
major cities like harkeev but they are
meeting fierce resistance from ukrainian
defense forces our charlie dagetta is in
kiev once again where some russian
forces now appear in fact they may be
less than 10 miles away from the city
center too close for comfort charlie
good morning
good morning to you tony ukrainian
authorities announced this morning they
will once again attempt to evacuate
civilians from some of the hardest hit
areas or at least try to get some
humanitarian aid out to them and as you
said that now includes suburbs around
the capital itself
on the outskirts of the capitol
residents run for their lives it's about
all they have left now hunkering down
hiding out and hoping the worst won't
happen is no longer an option when all
the windows are blown out when there's
no other choice but to grab the baby and
the single bag and brave sniper fire and
explosions to get away
the snipers have taken over my house
says valentina a school teacher they're
shooting in the direction of my son's
house my only son
not everyone gets away terrifying scenes
unfolding in the neighborhoods of urban
and buca just a few miles from the
capitol new satellite images of that
huge convoy north of the city suggest it
might finally be on the move with troops
repositioning in preparation for a
possible assault or siege of the capital
that's what's happening in harkev
ukraine's second largest city
but russia has paid a heavy price with
the bodies of russian soldiers littering
the ground
after two weeks of ferocious battle the
russian military has been unable to take
control
ukrainian soldiers and civilians may be
no match for russian artillery and
aerial bombardment
but once it comes to the ground assault
ukrainian troops have two advantages
they're fighting on their own turf
and they're determined to defend every
inch of it
they're fighting like soldiers of 1941.
yeah they have a lot of people here a
lot of tanks a lot of their vehicles and
technics but
we fight in our
land and we protect our families so
it doesn't matter how they fight we
fight like lions and they won't win
with multiple cities now under siege the
top priority is to again attempt the
evacuation of mariopol where hundreds of
thousands remain trapped in catastrophic
conditions
with no food water or electricity in
brutal sub-freezing temperatures
russia has called a meeting at the u.n
to discuss american military biological
activities in ukraine the white house
immediately dismissed the claim as a
false flag in an overnight address
president vladimir zelinsky said the
allegation that ukraine is developing
chemical weapons may just indicate that
russia is planning to launch its own
attack saying if you want to know what
russia's plans are just look at what
russia accuses others of
nate
charlie dagetta
thank you